صباح الخير لكل متابعي صباح العربيه ضيفت
اليوم رشحتها مجله فوز للعام الثالث على
التوالي ضمن قائمه افضل 40 شخصيه في الشرق
الاوسط المصممه السعوديه هنيدى سيرفي هي
ضيفه اليوم في هذا الحوار القصير يبقوا
معي
[موسيقى]
هنيدا ان سعيد جدا بهذا اللقاء بوجودك
وياه في صباح العربيه ومثل منقول احنا
العراقيين طالعه تخبلين اليوم شكرا مره
كثير العفو ان شاء الله يا رب تكون رحله
ناجحه اا ويكون ختامها مسك مع العربيه
شنو شعورك من تكونين على هذا الشارع اول
حاجه
شات كثير حلوه عندي بدايتها فيلم بريتي
وومنت يعني من واحنا صغار هذا الفيلم
بالنسبه لنا تصدرين كنترول بحس انه من
ناحيه الازياء جوليا روبوت
الشارع
والواحد هو بيمشي فيه كده يقول ميبي
اول حاجه احب اهني بكل للسيدات اللي كانوا
معايا من الشرق الاوسط كل واحده فيهم كانت
مميزه بطريقتها وناجحه في مجالها كون انه
انا اكون موجوده معهم فهذا دليل او هذا
شرف كبير ليا وان شاء الله يا رب يكون
خطوه من خطوات النجاح للبراند
[موسيقى]
دائما تاخذ المراه في مخططها بكل شيء
تسويه دائما تركز على موضوع المراه هل
الكلام صحيح
من اوائل اهتمامات اكلي هو
الفيجن حق البراند انه باول ومن همم
عن طريق الفاشن عن طريق الازياء وكمان
برده ان احنا او انه انا في البراند انجل
التراث والثقافه السعوديه عندنا ببعض
الاشياء اللي موجوده في في مناطقنا
المختلفه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ونخليها همم
يعني مناسب لكل السيده خلينا نرجع لوراء
نتحدث على البدايات وفي الصعوبات يلي مريت
بها حتى قدرت تحققين كل هذا النجاح اليوم
اكيد البدايات دائما صعبه لكنها جميله
لانه فيها الواحد بيتعلم اشياء كل مره
بيكتشف اشياء جديده بتزيد من همم معرفته
ثقافته بهذا المجال اللي احنا فيه همم لكن
الان الحمد لله المملكه العربيه السعوديه
عندنا وزاره الثقافه هيئه الازياء اللي
تابعه لها بتعمل برامج جدا جدا رائعه
بتدعم فيها كل المواهب وبتشجع لانهم
يوصلوا للمكان اللي لازم يوصل له
[موسيقى]
شنو رايك بهالدغيرات اللي صارت بالسعوديه
بالفتره الاخيره همم في نهضه جميله بتحصل
عندنا في السعوديه كانها همم يعني زي ما
تقول سنفني تكمل بعضها نهضه من القطاع
الاقتصادي في القطاع الثقافي في القطاع في
كل القطاعات طبعا واحده منهم قطاع الازياء
عن طريق الاغاني والمصمم والمذيع شنو
الرساله
اكيد طبعا انه انا ادعم المراه هي اللي
بتسوي بعرفها يعني ايش تكوني امراه قادره
حالمه توصل الهدفك من لانه كلكشن عندي بس
تروحيها من امراه
عبر العصور عبر التاريخ من ال من الماضي
من الحاضر والكوليكشن الجاي هيكون ما حد
يقول مين الانسبريشن بس ان شاء الله حاجه
برده
[موسيقى]
لا ههه
اه انجلينا جولي اكيد طبعا واحده من
السيدات اللي انا فعلا حاب انه البسهم
الدنيا
[موسيقى]
تعاون قريب معها
هو اول فيلم نزل بالسعوديه
افتتاح
عندنا صحيح
كان لها وقع اعلامي جميل جدا
واولات يعني
[ضحك]
الاهداف كبيره
والتصور كبير ان شاء الله اتمنى انه يكون
في عنده نايده افلام ستور حسب التوجه الا
ماشي على الدوله في تنميه قطاع الازياء ان
شاء الله يكون في مصانع بتحصل قريب الان
عندنا في السعوديه فهذا شيء اكيد هيساعد
كل احد بره انه يرجع وينمي هذا القطاع مع
التوجه اللبيسير
به هوايه ولكن يضيق الوقت لازم نختم ولكن
قبل الختام احب اسال لك شو تحبيني تقولي
لي كل المشاهدين من خلال صباح العربيه
واذا عندك نصيحه ههه
انا دائما اؤمن انه المراه همم هي اللي
بتصنع نفسها مهما كان في دواعي واسباب
للنجاح لو هي ما كانت حابه انها تكون
ناجحه وحب الناس تعمل نفسها كينونه ما راح
توصل لكده فخليك واثقه في نفسك عاملي
بنفسك وان شاء الله يا رب دايما تكوني
سعيده ومبسوطه وناجحه شكرا جزيلا على هذا
اللقاء